herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
boris johnson soll zurücktreten in
diesen minuten spricht er zur nation und
wir hören rheinwasser downing street
number to job
los
[Musik]
im display
systems
public
[Musik]
aber wo und
wie billig public
private coaching
l wird von mauro und juniper minister
ist in place in fresno bee sagt
der minister
alfabet
in eine kinder den ethischen to the beat
tier war natur world and say many people
s bank kritisch originalität so willing
to tackle problems in new ways to be
wild things von sun times
ich glaube bei manchen
auf youtube twitter ist golden er redet
von einer goldenen zukunft doch seine
zukunft endet heute die zukunft
zumindest als chef der konservativen
partei boris johnson der schwer schwer
schwer angeschlagene premierminister
großbritanniens und parteichef der
konservativen parteien großbritannien
hat seinen rücktritt erklärt seinen
rücktritt vom amt als chef der
konservativen partei er werde so lange
noch als premier im amt bleiben bis ein
neuer parteichef gefunden ist in
großbritannien ist es eben eine
tradition dass der parteichef wenn es
die regierende partei wenn diese partei
eine mehrheit hat im britischen
parlament dass es eine personalunion
gibt es zwischen dem parteichef eben und
dem amt des premierministers
das ist also das ende von boris johnson
viele haben sich gefragt wie kann das
eigentlich sein der mann hat sich über
monate an sein amt festgeklammert es hat
und ähnliche skandale affären gegeben
rücktrittsforderungen und immer wieder
hat er nein gesagt er bleibe im amt und
nun gibt er das amt er hat es selbst
bezeichnet als den schönsten job den es
in der welt gibt nun gibt er diesen
dieses amt diese arbeit auf nicht ganz
unfreiwillig wir wollen darüber reden
was ich getan hat denn gestern hat boris
johnson noch auf die frage ob er denn
zurücktreten wolle no no no gesagt ein
klares nein sogar mehrfach in
ausschüssen und vor dem parlament
gestern sah es also noch so aus als ob
er sich weiterhin an sein amt klammert
jetzt gibt es ab diana zimmermann ist
die leiterin unseres studios in london
diana wie ist das ganze einzuschätzen
was ist in den letzten stunden passiert
dass boris johnson nun doch sein amt
abgibt nun doch auf wiedersehen sagt und
zurücktritt
so ganz hat er es ja noch nicht getan
was passiert ist ist das in gestern am
reihenweise die minister abhanden
gekommen sind und dass heute morgen ganz
munter weiter gingen also der gerade
gestern nannte finanzminister hat heute
morgen gekündigt die
erziehungsministerin die dem
finanzminister folgte ebenfalls und so
geht es die ganze zeit weiter das heißt
er hat wirklich zunehmend mühe posten zu
besetzen er ruft jetzt schon leute ins
kabinett die ja früher herausgeschmissen
hat weil ihm deren drechsel positionen
nicht gefallen hat das heißt er wird
zunehmend verzweifelt diese posten zu
füllen und hat wohl eingesehen dass er
eben als vorsitzender der partei nicht
weitermachen kann dass er jetzt versucht
das irgendwie noch so hinzu dreck sind
dass er weiter premier bleiben kann das
ist natürlich wieder typisch boris
johnson der ja insgesamt nicht sehr
regelkonform agiert und kritiker
vermuten dass er einfach versuchen wird
über den sommer weiter zu kloppen also
ich denke zu schmieden und zu versuchen
ob es nicht doch noch irgendeine
möglichkeit gibt dass er die partei in
die zukunft wird von wir haben ja gerade
eben gehört in der in der rede er hat
erst mal aufgezählt seine ganzen
unglaublichen erfolge erstens das land
dem rexit vollzogen zu haben hat es
endlich geschafft dass großbritannien
tatsächlich den brics it durchgeführt
hat und dann hat er seine erfolge in der
impfkampagne herausgestellt und außerdem
große pläne gemacht was die konservative
partei alles in zukunft noch schaffen
soll und bedauert dass er nicht dabei
ist wie gesagt kritiker glauben dass er
versuchen könnte über den sommer doch
noch mal kraft zu sammeln und wieder
aufzustehen
du sagst es diana dass er ja noch nicht
so richtig ganz abtreten will dass man
das ja auch jetzt gerade in seiner rede
vor downing street number ten gehört hat
er hat gesagt er will of the
conservative party that should be on
july das heißt also er stellt fest und
konstatiert es ist der klare wille der
der konservativen partei seiner partei
dass es einen neuen parteichef ein neuen
führer geben solle er selbst sieht das
ja offenbar überhaupt nicht ein dass er
abtreten sollte sein argument ist die
ganze zeit dass er den konservativen
2009 10 einen enormen wahlsieg
verschafft hat mit 80 bestimmen also
sitzen mehrheit und dass er ein mandat
der der bürger großbritanniens habe und
nun trifft es sich so dass er
offensichtlich am gestern vor allen
dingen noch ich weiß nicht wie das heute
ist dazu hat er heute nichts gesagt
der ansicht ist bei neuwahlen könnten ja
die bürger noch mal entscheiden ob sie
nicht doch lieber ihn als die labour
partei wollen da trifft er sich
ausnahmsweise mal mit der forderung der
labour-partei die natürlich auch
neuwahlen möchte und sagt die
konservative partei sei von dieser
ganzen geschichte so beschmutzt das egal
wer jetzt neu komme nicht der richtige
sein könne denn die müssten sich erst
mal neu sortieren und sich darüber im
klaren werden wenn sie über die letzte
zeit gestützt haben
du hast es auch gerade gesagt und wir
alle haben es gerade live gehört wie
boris johnson die erfolge aufgezählt hat
er möchte also eigentlich würde gerne
das weitermachen was man versprochen hat
man habe den black city angeschafft man
hätte sozusagen wieder die macht von
brüssel zurück nach auf die insel geholt
man sei hervorragend durch die pandemie
gekommen und leading the westin standing
up against rascher also man sei doch
sozusagen die führende macht in europa
die sich so zu sagen die russland die
stirn bietet investitionen in die
infrastruktur und und und kein wort von
chaos skandalen und affären vielleicht
zählst du auch noch mal auf was die
realität eigentlich ist denn wenn man
anfängt eine liste zu machen an
skandalen partys in downing street
während das corinna lockt 1 unter und
und vielleicht hast du auch noch einfach
mal zusammen was denn eigentlich die
wahrheit ist warum ist eigentlich
unfassbar ist dass er es bis hierhin
geschafft hat und sich im amt halten
halten können es hängt vor allen dingen
damit an damit beginnt die ganze
geschichte und damit hört sie im grunde
genommen auch wieder auf dass er eben
liegt er hat schon als journalist sachen
erfunden die einfach nicht stimmten
meistens negative dinge über europa
politik in brüssel sein ehemaliger chef
hat ihm attestiert dass er ein
gespaltenes verhältnis zur wahrheit habe
chef der times und ihn deswegen
rausgeschmissen dennoch ist er erst zum
londoner bürgermeister geworden und dann
zum außenminister als außenminister hat
er sich verschiedene dinge zu schulden
kommen lassen bei denen jeder andere
außenminister einer westlichen
demokratie
zurückgetreten wäre nicht so boris
johnson er hat intrigiert er hat die
ganze zeit versucht hinten rum zu
arbeiten und immer wenn er mit einer
lüge konfrontiert wird leugnet er es
erst dann sagt er oder habe ich etwas
übersehen und entschuldigung und macht
dann weiter das ist erstmal so das
grundkonzept der ganzen geschichte das
andere ist dass er ein echt guter
kampagnen führer ist das irgendwie haben
wir gerade eben noch mal gesehen das ist
eine rücktrittsrede die eigentlich
aussieht wie eine wahlkampfrede die er
gehalten hat und das ist eben seine
große stärke dass er irgendwie im
kampfmodus wirklich ziemlich viel reist
und sehr charismatisch ist und die leute
ihn deswegen vertraut haben dann aber im
amt selber hat er eben keinen plan
gehabt und hat ihn immer noch nicht und
auch jetzt ist ein plan ja nicht
vorhanden sondern der bild vor allen
dingen irgendwie weiter kämpfen im amt
hat er ist dann tatsächlich geschafft
diesen dragset vertrag zustande zu
kommen bekommen das wertet er als großen
erfolg und es werden viele in seiner
partei als großen erfolg wirtschaftlich
muss man einfach noch mal ganz klar
sagen dass der exit eine katastrophe ist
dessen folgen sich jetzt erst langsam
von den katastrophalen folgen der
pandemie auseinander die lassen und die
einfach das land über einen langen
zeitraum noch wirklich schwer belasten
wird es ist ganz klar dass der handel
mit der eu massiv zurückgegangen ist
dass die hoffnungen dass es
handelsverträge mit anderen ländern gibt
die das in irgendeiner form ausgleichen
könnten sich als absolut trügerisch
erwiesen hat und auch politisch hat der
praxis natürlich großbritannien ganz
massiv geschwächt und dann kamen die
ganzen geschichten mit party geld an dem
im kampf an wir haben noch dazwischen zu
beginn ist es ganz klar dass
großbritannien zu spät in den walk down
gegangen ist und über die pandemie jahre
häufig zu früh wieder raus das hat viele
menschen das leben gekostet die
restriktionen waren teilweise lasch es
war das erste land das den freedom day
gefeiert hat und die masken pflegt
abgelegt hat und es trotzdem auch immer
noch relativ viele tote im letzten jahr
gesehen hat dann kam natürlich die
impfkampagne und die wir tatsächlich ein
großer erfolg großbritannien hat zuerst
in europa angefangen zu impfen und hat
einen großen erfolg verzeichnet und auch
die auf diesen zweiten erfolg kommt
boris johnson immer wieder zu sprechen
dann aber kam party gate und das hat ihm
im grunde genommen das genick gebrochen
die terrasse in downing street
reihenweise partys gefeiert wurden
während viele leute eben weder zu den
beerdigungen ihrer verwandten und
angehörigen gehen konnten noch sie
sterbend im krankenhaus begleiten
durften und das hat tatsächlich in
großbritannien für sehr großen unmut
gesorgt und hat bei vielen menschen dazu
geführt dass sie sich vom premier
abgewandt haben das letzte was ich dazu
noch sagen möchte ist dass er außerdem
bei seiner fraktion zunehmend unbeliebt
geworden ist weil er unglaublich viele
parteien gesetzesvorhaben eingebracht
hat die abgeordneten gegen ihren eigenen
willen dazu getrieben hat mit ihm
zustimmen um dann nachdem es einen
backlash aus der öffentlichen meinung
gehabt diese ganzen vorhaben wieder
zurückzuholen und damit hat er seine
fraktion zermürbt und auch das
vorbereitet was wir jetzt gerade sehen
wir merken ist ja schon die liste der
skandale der affären ist im grunde um
unendlich lang und eine fast
belustigende geschichte gab es ja auch
noch die rede wo man sich fragen konnte
hat er denn da auch gerade vor der party
gefeiert ab und zu viel getrunken als er
über payback
gesprochen hat wir erinnern uns also
sensationell muss man sich noch mal
angucken da haben nicht nur die
anwesenden die presse minister politiker
die köpfe geschüttelt und gedacht hören
wir da richtig sondern die ganze welt
hat sich da also auch gewundert dass nun
viele dinge gegeben du hast es gerade
gesagt da wäre jeder andere jeder andere
außenminister jeder andere premier wäre
da aus charme schon
zurückgetreten ist es so dass ein boris
johnson eben wie pech an diesem amt
geklebt hat weil er eben ganz einfach
kein schamgefühl hat keine skrupel hat
und eben eigentlich nur alles dafür
getan hat um eben im amt zu bleiben ja
ich glaube er hält sich tatsächlich für
den geeignetsten kandidaten dass das
scheint verwunderlich aber das hat ein
bisschen mit seiner ausbildung zu tun er
war wie sehr viele britische premiers
auf dem elite-internat iten und da wird
die junge elite eben darauf vorbereitet
dass sie wichtige ämter im land
übernimmt und dass sie sich dieser
verantwortung stellen und man könnte
sagen dass die ziele eatons boris
johnson ganz besonders gut gefruchtet
haben man muss sich aber natürlich auch
fragen auf welche kosten auf wessen
kosten und ob die moral eben komplett
auf der strecke bleiben darf wenn man
das anstrebt und das ist natürlich auch
die frage die sich jetzt die
konservative partei stellen muss die es
geschafft hat mit ihm die mehrheit zu
erringen und ihm dafür dankbar ist und
ihnen jetzt fallen lässt nicht etwa
deswegen weil er diese ganzen skandale
produziert hat sondern weil sie das
gefühl haben er ist nicht mehr tragbar
und sie werden keine wahlen weil mit ihm
gewinnen verlieren also ihre sitze und
das bis zu einem grad der der schon
wirklich sehr verwunderlich ist muss man
sagen dass dieser massen rücktritte die
wir jetzt in den letzten zwei tagen
gesehen haben nicht vorher geschehen
sind
ja die ja erstmal vielen vielen dank man
kann über diesen mann der heute
zumindest den rücktritt vom amt des
parteivorsitzenden
gesprochen hat und diesen erklärt hat
noch stunde lang sprechen er ist ein
bisschen schnell aus der downing street
gekommen die türe hat sich etwas
schneller geöffnet als die technik
bereit war wir haben also so die ersten
30 sekunden verpasst wir wollen einfach
nochmal in den beginn seiner rede wo er
natürlich das entscheidende gesagt hat
reinhören
so wir wollten jetzt eigentlich den
besen gemein ich hoffe dass johnsons
rede noch einmal vorspielen wo er eben
den satz gesagt hat it is clearly the
wheel of the conservative party dass der
schnee an new leader was übersetzt eben
heißt es ist offensichtlich der klare
wille der konservativen partei also
seiner partei das ist einen neuen führer
einen neuen parteivorsitzenden geben
solle was eben sehr klar deutlich macht
dass johnson von dem amt des
vorsitzenden seiner partei zurück tritt
dass er den weg frei macht es zeigt aber
eben auch das haben wir mit diana gerade
besprochen dass er selbst davon nicht
überzeugt ist
jetzt haben wir andreas stammen unseren
london korrespondenten eindeutig in der
downing street vor downing street number
ten wo eben vor 20 minuten die türe
aufging und die welt gebannt hin schaute
denn etwas fast unmöglich geglaubte es
ist passiert boris johnson der nun
wirklich über monate und jahre an seinem
amt fest geklammert hat hat tatsächlich
seinen rücktritt erklärt andreas knie
kannst du das beschreiben erstmal die
frage auch an dich im hintergrund habe
ich da so viele was ich leute rufen
gehört ist das jubelfeier in der
benachbarten straße gewesen
also wenn man hier runter schaut dann
kommt man raus aus der downing street
auf die hauptstraße sozusagen und dort
wurde gefeiert dort man die gegner von
boris johnson aktiv die haben auch
ordentlich sound gemacht und haben sich
bemerkbar gemacht und dazu kamen dann
auch noch dass das soundsystem hier die
die die anlage ausfiel und es überhaupt
nicht zu hören mal was er sagt dass
vielleicht ein bisschen eine
zusammenfassung seiner regentschaft
pleiten pech und pannen
es war trotzdem emotional es haben sich
hier noch mal überall die mitarbeiter
aus der downing street aufgebaut auch
die gekreuzten der getreuen aus dem
parlament waren zu sehen sein und seine
frau mit dem letzten oder vorerst
letzten kind die haben wir zwei zusammen
wie viele insgesamt so hat darüber redet
man ja die zahl der kinder und es war
aber muss man sagen im vergleich als
theresa may ging oder auch david cameron
weniger emotional es war klar hier geht
einer der wirklich raus getrieben wurde
der
unausweichliche der der nicht gehen will
der wollte gehen und das hat man
natürlich auch gemerkt dass das ist klar
er hat hier einfach überreizt und es
viel zu lange viel zu lange
hinausgezögert man könnte sagen das
spiel ist nun endgültig aus was er eben
lange versucht hat weiterzuspielen und
diana eben auch erklärt wir merken doch
ein bisschen dass da immer noch der
versuch es mit einem hintertürchen noch
im spiel ein bisschen zu bleiben jetzt
haben wir aber nochmal die
eingehenden worte also die den beginn
von johnstons rede vorliegen hören wir
einfach gemeinsam andreas noch mal rein
die
partie
war
[Musik]
wieder
ya also wie gesagt boris johnson sagte
sei der wille der
parlamentarischen fraktionen also der
konservativen partei das ist ein neuen
führer einen neuen anführer geben solle
und er habe das ganze also besprochen
und bis eben dieser neue parteichef im
amt sei würde er eben weitermachen jetzt
müssen wir dich einfach fragen anderes
als jemand der sich da auskennt was
heißt das genau wir wissen dass das amt
des premierministers und das amt
parteivorsitzender das ja in
personalunion in der regel gemacht hat
ist das jetzt irgendwie ein
hintertürchen muss man zwischen den
zeilen lesen dass boris johnson doch
irgendwie versucht noch weiter durch zu
kommen es gibt ja auch die sommerferien
was eventuell ja vielleicht auch die
wahl dieses neuen parteivorsitzenden
verzögern könnte
ja also da gibt es kein hintertürchen
das ist der standard prozess ist ja klar
es muss weiterhin eine geschäftsführende
regierung geben und die tory partei wird
sich jetzt aufstellen es gibt ein allen
langes bewerberfeld die sich dann
aufstellen werden da wird man dann
innerhalb der fraktion aus sieben immer
nach wahlverfahren das dauert und dann
wird es am ende ein endspiel geben
zwischen den beiden letzten
verbleibenden kandidaten kandidatinnen
und die werden da sich dann der
parteibasis stellen und dort wird dann
entschieden die tory parteibasis 100000
bis 150000 so genau weiß das keiner die
werden dann über den nächsten
parteivorsitzende und damit auch über
den nächsten premier entscheiden das ist
felsenfest es war die große frage hier
heute ob nicht zu viel porzellan
zerbrochen zerbrochen ist zwischen
partei fraktion und boris johnson dass
er diese diese paar monate dann
überbrücken kann aber er hat sich
dadurch gesetzt vielleicht ein letzter
kleiner triumph aber danach ist dann
auch schluss und die große frage ist
eben wie er wollte er wollte eben
bleiben es gibt sogar die spekulation
ich meine das ist jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen fies aber dass er gar nicht
weiß wohin es heißt immer hat
finanzielle probleme in seinem leben
außerhalb des amtssitz das wird man
sehen und hat vor allen dingen keinen
platz wo er hingehen kann insofern hat
er zumindest jetzt noch mal ein paar
monate zeit sich eine neue bleibe zu
suchen aber es gibt da keinen weg mehr
für ihn zurück es gibt da keine
hintertürchen das ist glaube ich das
steht fest und die opposition hat
angekündigt noch mal ein vertrauens eine
vertrauensfrage im parlament zu stellen
die anders als die vertrauensfrage in
einer fraktion gehandhabt wird und da
kommt es natürlich zu einer absurden
situation denn im endeffekt muss die
partei die kein vertrauen den premier
chance mehr hat dann das vertrauen
aussprechen um eine mögliche neuwahl zu
verhindern aber das ist natürlich tief
in der britischen politik aber am ende
des tages steht fest das was ich
wirklich über eine woche hin
abgezeichnet hat oder in den letzten
drei tagen johnson geht und das ist
unausweichlich wenn es auch schon mal
als geschäftsführender regierungschef
wahrscheinlich noch bis oktober weiter
geht dann denken wir ganz herzlich
andrea stamm für diese analyse für eben
die erklärung im hintergrund wie wird
glaube ich gespielt you never walk alone
also partystimmung in der nähe von
downing street number 10 warum weil es
eben doch ein entscheidender tag ist
eine ära geht zu ende und ob es eine
positive ära ist oder eine katastrophale
er das muss dann jeder selbst
beschädigen und entscheiden ja wir haben
es also erlebt boris johnson hat seinen
rücktritt erklärt endlich werden viele
sagen sowohl bei der oppositionspartei
als auch in seiner eigenen partei
oppositionschef kierst aber von der
labour partei begrüßte den erwarteten
rücktritt bereits und hat gesagt das
seien gute neuigkeiten und er fügte
hinzu aber es hätte schon vor langer
zeit passieren soll gestern schon
titelten die britischen zeitungen
todesstoß für den premier johnson am
rande des abgrunds da waren zwei
schwergewichte zwei minister nämlich der
finanzminister und der
gesundheitsminister
zurückgetreten hinzu kamen noch zahllose
rücktritte von staatssekretären und
anderen regierungsmitgliedern das
interessante war dass boris johnson
danach gestern vor dem parlament in
einer fragestunde zur rede gestellt
wurde rede und antwort geben musste und
da klar sagte dass er weiter im amt sein
bleiben möchte es ein noch so viel zu
tun und auch später in einem
parlamentarischen ausschuss war eben
seine antwort auf die frage ob er denn
nun zurücktreten würde
und heute ist er zurückgetreten
soweit zdf heute live is live miterlebt
und wie der premiere gesagt hat der
weitere zeitplan wird noch bekannt
gegeben es bleibt also spannend was in
london in den nächsten tagen passieren
wird vielen dank für das interesse